ces gens-là ils espèrent qu'ils vont se
débarrasser de leur propre
inexistants historiques
pour vous
d'abord il faut commencer par la fin
c'est à dire par aujourd'hui les
problèmes qui font comprendre sur 88 ils
sont là aujourd'hui et 68 ça a été le la
rencontre le mélange de la collision
entre deux conceptions de la gauche et
qui sont toujours en train de
s'engueuler aujourd'hui sans avoir
trouvé une réponse la première c'est la
jeunesse des problèmes culturels des
problèmes de sexualité de minorité etc
qui sont des choses neuves et puis elles
sont tellement neuves qu'elles n'ont pas
d'appui politique n'ont pas d'appui
l'engager une immeuble idéologique et
alors on recourt aux vieux monde
c'est-à-dire la classe ouvrière etc on
fait semblant d'être ensemble on fait
semblant de dire les mains fragiles des
étudiants vont passer le drapeau combien
ce choix à faire entre un langage qui ne
correspond plus à une réalité et une
réalité qui n'a pas encore de langage
c'est ça la France de gauche des 50
dernières années et c'est ça le sens
profond de Mai 68 alors pour s'amuser on
pourrait dire il y a les gens de la
Sorbonne qui sont
les Trotski etc le vieux monde ouvriers
et puis il y a les gens de Nanterre
comme Venise etc libertaire plus ou
moins anti-communiste et qui parle des
problèmes de culture de jeunesse parce
qu'en fait on a inventé dans la pratique
la réalité de la jeunesse comme acteur
politique alors que d'autres des
sociologues même émis non on dit la
jeunesse ça n'existe pas comme les
femmes ça n'existe pas tout ça c'est des
fronts de la lutte générale de classe
bon la difficulté qu'on a à faire c'est
un entre toujours pas
français quand ils ont voté contre la
Constitution européenne ils ont voté
pour dire il faut foot en l'air
l'économie de marché des choses qui
étaient devenues un langage sens aucun
répondant vous savez le mouvement
ouvrier français c'est pas en 68 1069
c'est quand même pas très différent
c'est lips etc et après c'est fini c'est
pas par hasard que que ça vous j'ai un
peu autour de 68 parce que c'est pas
pour se rappeler 68 c'est pour dire
est-ce que quand même on va pas finir
par y arriver à savoir de quoi il faut
parler qu'est-ce qu'il faut changer dans
la société et avec quelle vocabulaire
quel
motivation et ensuite vous comprenez il
y a eu cette catastrophe qui s'appelle
François Mitterrand c'est-à-dire qui a
fait rendu officiel la pensée du Parti
communiste
passé au Parti socialiste pour définir
la gauche et une gauche
complètement imaginaire ou non sans
aucun contenu quand tout ça ça fait ça
foutu le camp et maintenant on peut
espérer enfin on peut espérer puisque il
y a eu une défaite de la droite quand
même importantes on peut espérer que les
problèmes de reconstitution d'une gauche
iront de pair avec la réflexion
simple mais nécessaire sur mai 68 devant
la droite en France c'est qui c'est très
riche et très pauvres c'est le monde
rural et c'est les très beaux quartiers
et les golden boys ces gens-là ont été
bouleversées
bouleversé j'ai un prête insulter par le
langage qu'on a entendu en mai 68 qui
est devenu celui après ça les bobos si
vous n'avez pas d'imagination mais
disons de toute cette catégorie de
travailleurs et de classe moyenne fondée
sur la connaissance et le débat et
l'image et la communication et tout ça
bon cette vieille France
qui ne fait rien enfin Sarkozy quand
même c'est pas grave
ils espèrent qu'ils vont se débarrasser
de leur propre
inexistants historiques
évidemment leur inexistence historique
elle est là pour l'éternité
[Musique]